[تصفيق]
اليوم اريدكم تتفاعلوا معي اريد اشوف ديكم
مرتفعه فوق من
منكم رجع بيته الا ويحس انه يبى يطلع مره
ثانيه كيف ايوه من من
منكم يفضل انه يقعد في بيت حد ثاني
كيف من
منكم يحب انه يقعد في المقهى مع رباع ته
لين صار وقت
النوم من منكم جالس بسالته سالط بيته الا
ويحس عمره انه راح غرفه النوم لانه متملل
وم يحس بالانتماء
كيف
ايوه صراحه اني معكم بيتنا حن اكون صريحه
معكم جميل جدا لكن غرفتي للاسف
ورديه مال قبل 15
سنه اريدكم تتخيلوا معي بيت فيه كل
احتياجاتكم بيت مكان يعطيكم الاسترخاء
والاستمتاع
[موسيقى]
والتامل مكان لدوا فيه قهوتكم على اطلاله
الحديقه الجميله لكن هيش اهم شي الحديقه
تكون مضلله يكون تستخدموها في الصيف
بعد مسؤوليه
المعماريين ان نصمم بيوت لكم
انتم تغيرت
الاوقات البيت ما صار غرفه نوم مجلس
وصاله المتطلبات توسعت
في شيء صار حدث اثر
علينا كوفيد ادى الى توعيه الناس
لاحتياجاتهم في المنزل وايش هي
استخداماتهم في هذه
المساحات اذا علينا ان نواكب هذا التغيير
ليش لان سنه
المكان كيف ممكن ان نعزز انسنه المكان
هناك الكثير من النظريات منها البيوفيليا
والديمو والفن شويه والقا وغير
ذلك وتتمحور كل هذه النظريات على ثلاث
مفاهيم البيئه الصحه
والروح اذا اكتملت هذه المفاهيم الثلاثه
في المساحات المعماريه اذا انت تشعر
بالانتماء
مكان تحس فيه بالراحه
والامان اذا علينا ان نواكب هذا التغيير
لان سنه
المكان كيف ممكن ان احنا نعزز انسنه
المكان في المساحات المعماريه او ما هي
المعاير اولا خلونا نبدا في البيئه نحتاج
ان نحس
بالطاقه وان نكون من الحديقه من الطبيعه
يعني فايش المفروض
نسويه البيت لازم يم الطبيعه اللي
حول والشمس ايش احسن من الشمس انها تدخل
بيتك والهواء الطلق اذا النوافذ
اماكنها وحجمها جدا مهم في التصميم
المعماري
ثانيا الصحه
نحتاج
للتفاعل اذا مصمم
مساحات تعزز من هذا التفاعل مساحات متصله
مع بعض ليش لكي نتفاعل مع اهل
البيت ثالثا
الروح نحتاج ان نشعر بالسعاده اذا ايش
نستخدم الالوان والمواد الطبيعيه اللي
تحسسنا بهذا الشيء واكيد انا اعرف ان انتم
كلكم تعرفوا ان بعض الالوان لها عائد على
المزاج مثل اللون الازرق الاخضر
الاصفر وممكن بعد ان نحتاج
للشعور بالانشراح
والراحه اذا نخلق مساحات واسعه
تشعرنا
بال العظمه او وتشعرنا
بالفخامه ومساحات ثانيه نصممها تكون صغيره
تشعرنا بالدفء
والحنيه اذا تلاحظوا كل هذه المفاهيم
الثلاث متصله مع بعض اذا انت كنت متصل
بالبيئه اذا اصبحت صحي واذا تواجدت هذه
المفاهيم اذا هي غذاء للروح وتشعر
بالانتماء اذا حققنا انسنه المكان
اذا بيتكم انا بقول لكم شي ترى انسنه
المكان شيء ما بصعب ابدا ان
نحققه اذا بيتكم من بني خلاص قدروا انكم
تشتغلوا على الاشياء اللي ذكرناها لكن اذا
بيتكم بعدده ما بمبني وتفكروا انكم تخططوا
بيت خلونا نشوف كيف ممكن ان احنا نصمم من
البدايه تصميم صحيح مع
المعماري
هذا
بيت واكيد كلكم تشوفوا ان ذا البيت متكرر
في كل مكان مكعب اني اعطيه صراحه نجمه
واحده حتى ولو كانت فيه المساحات او كانت
فيه المفاهيم اللي ذكرناها قبل بعد نجمه
واحده وحتى ولو كانت في البلكونات او
الزينه اعطيه نجمتين اصلا بقول لكم شيء
ايش فائده البلكونه ذي لا فيها خصوصيه
وانا متاكده انكم تستعملوها والشمس تدكم
ايش
الفائده خلينا نشوف ايش البيت اللي هو
ثلاث نقوم لو تلاحظوا ان النوافذ دخلت في
هذا المكعب في تشكيله هذه العماره اذا ايش
حققنا ان الشمس ما تضربنا
مباشره لكن نستفيد من الاضاء الطبيعيه
ايش البيت اللي هو اربع
نجوم البلكونه راحت اللي ما نستخدمها
وصارت من ضمن هيئه العماره وايش استفدنا
مكان فيه خصوصيه ومظلل ومليون بالم
بتستعملو وتستمتعوا فيه ابكم تدقق في
المساحه الرصاصيه اللي
ورا كلكم عندكم مساحه ورا بيوتكم تستمتعوا
فيها لكن ايش يصير لو غيرنا
[موسيقى]
العماره صارت عندكم هذه المساحه على فكره
بقولكم شيء الارض نفس المساحه البيت نفس
البنيه نفس مساحه البنا ما تغير شيء لكن
غيرنا تفكيرنا في تكوين هذه العماره اذا
انت صارت عندك مساحه فيها خصوصيه ومثل مثل
ما تعرفوا احنا نريد الخصوصيه وغير كذ
بشكل هذه العماره حققنا اللي هي مكان مضلل
نقدر نستمتع فيه في الشتاء في الصيف هذا
هو الهدف من العماره
الجيده الحين هذذه المساحه
الجديده تخيلوا معي لو كانت
حديقه تستمتعوا فيها تشربوا قهوتكم
تستانسوا وغير كذ لو تلاحظوا الغرفه اللي
على اليسار كانت دريشه واحده الحين صارت
فيها
دريشتي دخلت
الشمس حسيت بشعور حلو صارت عندكم اطلالات
اكثر على
الحديقه العماره لا محدوده واب اقوللكم
شيء انا ماب الحل الوحيد في هذا الحل السي
شيب احنا نسميه في الاي شيب في الاتش شيب
في عده اشياء ممكن تدخل شيء تطلع شي تزيد
شيء هنا يكون التصميم
وتاثيره
اذا ايش بيصير لو احنا زدنا من احتياجاتكم
انتم من متطلباتكم انتم تخيلوا ذي المساحه
انتم بغيتوا تزيدوا فيها مثلا الزينه
الظلال الخشبيه او شي كذ سار مكان تحسوا
انكم تنتمون له مكان لكم مكان مميز
بالتالي بالتالي ايش حققنا انسنه المكان
وهذا هو الهدف من
العماره
البيت يعني بلا حدود ومرن صح انا بقول لكم
شيء عن سالفه
مرن العماره
الصحيحه اذا كان يعني البيت مرن من
البدايه وفكرنا ان نخطط بالطريقه الصحيحه
انتم ممكن في المستقبل تزيدوا شيء تنقصوا
شيء وم يطلع شكله
مرقع فهذه
العماره بيت مرن بلا
حدود العماره
روح
معطاه تلبي
احتياجاتكم وتصير معكم في مسيره حياتكم
[تصفيق]
uk